[Música]
Bienvenidos a reporteros el magacín de
los grandes reportajes de la redacción
de Franz 24 so hernia Fernández
comenzamos
desde el comienzo de la guerra decenas
de miles de musulmanes han tomado las
armas o han colaborado de otras formas
en los esfuerzos bélicos Aunque Ucrania
es mayoritariamente cristiana también
alberga acerca de medio millón de
musulmanes que representan alrededor del
1% de la población la mayoría son
tártaros de crimea los musulmanes del
cáucaso y en particular de chechenia
también se han unido a la lucha
alistándose en los batallones de
voluntario chechemos junto con los
ucranianos no solo defienden Ucrania y
sus valores sino que luchan contra un
enemigo común Rusia raíz de abusaidet y
Anahí son los autores de este reporteros
veamos la historia
[Música]
una ambulancia regresando del frente a
bordo un soldado con una bala en el
abdomen todo bien Es normal estaremos
allí en 10 minutos
la guerra convirtió a Iris My Love en
cuidador voluntario
desde el primero de diciembre se han
llevado a cabo evacuaciones todos los
días en estos momentos hay peleas
callejeras así que tenemos soldados con
heridas de bala
no se nos permite ir más allá la
posición del hospital debe permanecer
secreta said se reunirá con nosotros en
la siguiente parada la mezquita
constantinovca
a 26 kilómetros del frente El ruido de
los proyectiles no cesa
vestido con su trading el imán y antiguo
muffiti sigue dirigiendo la oración del
viernes
en tiempos de guerra los textos
religiosos resultan de manera especial
el imán Llama a su comunidad a defender
la patria
y absolute creo que lo que estamos
haciendo es la yihad porque según la
charia podemos proteger nuestras vidas
nuestras familias y nuestras propiedades
llame a proteger Ucrania no utilicé la
palabra yihad porque Ucrania es un país
laico
Ucrania tiene una gran mayoría cristiana
pero medio millón de musulmanes
representan el 1% de la población y
muchos de ellos se han movilizado desde
la invasión rusa
es el caso de Mohamed Alien
aquí una batalla del 27 de febrero
cuando un pequeño grupo de rusos
irrumpió en la ciudad
ese día la escuela de su ciudad quedó
destrozada
[Aplausos]
lo vimos todo con nuestros propios ojos
la escuela seguía Ardiendo y se percibía
el olor de los cuerpos quemados
es imposible comparar esto con otra cosa
un detonante para Mohamed
se unió entonces a la comprometida
comunidad musulmana en harquif llegas
Justo a tiempo con los platos hermano
vamos a comer conoce a Ajá murat
capellán voluntario del ejército
como saben Nuestros hombres están
muriendo
los jóvenes van a la guerra y estamos
enterrando a muchos de ellos sin ni
siquiera poder identificarlos
podemos perdonar esto no en absoluto se
trata de un nuevo compromiso para la
comunidad musulmana acostumbrada a pasar
desapercibida
antes el sistema político seguía la
propaganda rusa política
se acusó a los musulmanes de ser
terroristas
pero ahora la sociedad ha madurado
tal como somos
esto nos permite ser más activos
en el centro cultural islámico todos
participan en el esfuerzo bélico
después de su trabajo Natalia Manzur se
dedicó a fabricar velas para los
soldados de las trincheras es para que
puedan calentarse preparar la comida y
tener algo de comodidad
es una forma de decirles que no los
olvidamos
queremos ayudarles porque es un problema
de todos nosotros Natalia aprendió esta
receta a conservas rellenas de parafina
en YouTube
en estos días oscuros poder contribuir a
nuestra manera aporta esperanza
como me siento
mi corazón está lleno de alegría
me siento orgullosa de poder hacer
aunque sea una pequeña cosa
y ya tuyo
llamo alto
al día siguiente
cargan velas y otros suministros
Los dos amigos parten para abastecer a
los Soldados del frente
destino
[Música]
con la guerra todo puede cambiar en un
segundo
Así que siempre tenemos un plan pero
solo Dios sabe lo que ocurrirá
[Música]
nos acercamos a la ciudad bajo el fuego
de la ofensiva rusa
para llegar a las posiciones ucranianas
tenemos que tomar esta pista de tierra
pero al entrar en la ciudad
chocamos contra un bloque de hormigón
rompí la llanta
[Música]
tienen un cable
acércala un poco más
estamos atrapados entre dos posiciones
de artillería hay que evacuar a los
periodistas la prensa no puede quedarse
por seguridad
decidió embarcarse rápidamente con Los
Hombres de este Batallón cheno
nos adentramos en las entrañas de la
ciudad en medio de las duchas callejeras
mcmut es una ciudad fantasma
no cayó muy lejos
el capellán jamurar lleva las noticias
del frente desde el sótano
ayer oímos que Los Invasores rusos se
habían acercado a bamut
pero nuestros hermanos acaban de
decirnos que han conseguido lograr su
retirada
la resistencia nos llena de alegría
su presencia es un valioso apoyo para
estos soldados
nuestro hermano regularmente
[Música]
juntos ganaremos
ucranianos y chechenos luchan codo a
codo contra un enemigo común Rusia
muslinchelo y eski es el comandante del
Batallón checheno Shake Manzur Él lleva
combatiendo en el don vast desde 2015
los rusos nos forzaron a esta guerra y
por eso tenemos que luchar y sobrevivir
de todas las formas posibles
la mayoría de las veces utilizamos
tácticas de guerrilla Porque no tenemos
equipo militar suficiente para
enfrentarnos de igual a igual
no tenemos ni tanques ni artillería ni
lanzacohetes
al salir nurradin se asegura de que no
nos espera ningún francotirador
para este último la lucha contra los
rusos comenzó en su tierra natal tenía
14 años
Creo que nunca perdonaré lo que hicieron
los rusos en mi país nunca lo perdonaré
hasta que muera Lucharé contra este
régimen hasta destruir
visto
creo que a estas alturas Europa y el
mundo entero ya han comprendido Quiénes
son los terroristas
a más de 700 kilómetros en kiev maga es
otra figura de esta lucha tras estudiar
en Francia este checheno se alistó en el
batallón
especializado en inteligencia testifica
con el rostro oculto
lo que ves ahí es la ametralladora
pesada
es la ametralladora rusa que tomamos de
isium
había muchos tanques abandonados
capturas de guerra que permiten a Maga y
a su Batallón apoyar al ejército
parece que Ucrania está dispuesta a
llegar hasta el final así que les
ayudaremos y estaremos a su lado hasta
que ganen
la virtual mira aquí
Este es el símbolo de los tártaros
ucranianos Y chechenos esto es defender
Ucrania juntos contra la destrucción del
terror rojo
el pueblo tártaro es originario de
crimea se convirtieron al islam en el
siglo xiv y hoy representan la mayor
comunidad musulmana de Ucrania
también Ellos están en la mira de Putin
[Música]
todos estos libros proceden de los
territorios ocupados se están
recuperando porque muchas bibliotecas de
allí han sido destruidas
es directora adjunto del instituto
cultural de Ucrania de origen tártaro
intenta preservar la identidad de su
pueblo
al principio en 2014 los rusos
intentaron comprarnos pero casi todo el
pueblo tártaro dijo que no
tenemos una patria Ucrania y nuestra
tierra es crimea
si se intenta sacrificar crimea y
regalársela a los rusos esta guerra se
convertirá en la guerra de la próxima
generación
hoy Alí la comunidad tártara entierran a
uno de sus soldados
se Irán
en esta guerra murió un tártaro de
crimea y un musulmán ucraniano más
fue un hombre valiente que luchó por su
padre a
crimeam para los combatientes del
Batallón crime solo la victoria de
Ucrania devolverá la dignidad a los
fallecidos
es muy difícil expresar todo lo que
siento para la mayoría de nosotros era
un hermano ni siquiera conozco las
palabras para describirlo Unidos que
estábamos
Es una pérdida muy dura para todos
nosotros y nos vengaremos
el precio de la guerra lágrimas y
derramamiento de sangre
se abrió una nueva parcela musulmana de
este cementerio cristiano El cuerpo del
Soldado es enterrado en la tierra por la
que dio su vida
hasta que hay reporteros de la semana
recuerde que para sintonizar esta y las
emisiones anteriores puede visitar
nuestro sitio web France 24.com hasta la
próxima
[Música]